[Musique]
les sénateurs agissent
liberté des médias les sénateurs
appellent la Commission européenne à
revoir sa copie
renforcer la liberté et l'indépendance
des médias les sénateurs partagent bien
évidemment l'objectif principal de la
proposition de règlement européen sur la
liberté des médias en revanche il met en
garde contre un texte qui n'apparaît pas
conforme aux principes de subsidiarité
qui garantit que l'Union européenne
reste dans son rôle et intervient à bon
escient sur le fond le pluralisme et la
liberté de la presse érigée en droit
fondamentaux ne peuvent être défendus
par une approche seulement fondée sur le
marché intérieur européen les sénateurs
rappellent que ces droits vont de pair
avec la diversité culturelle et
linguistique de l'Europe
l'Union européenne doit donc respecter
les législations des États en la matière
surtout quand elles sont très
protectrices anciennes et robustes comme
c'est le cas en France
la grande loi du 29 juillet 1881 sur la
liberté de la presse et la loi du 30
septembre 1986 sur la liberté de
communication audiovisuelle sont des
acquis très solides qu'il ne faut
toucher que d'une main tremblante ont
déclaré les rapporteurs de la commission
des affaires européennes Catherine Morin
de saillie Florence blatrix compta et
André gatelin les sénateurs s'inquiète
d'un risque de nivellement par le bas si
une harmonisation européenne était
imposée il relève une incohérence qui
consiste à réunir dans une même
législation européenne deux écosystèmes
très différents celui de la presse est
celui des médias audiovisuels et
numériques
le Sénat n'est pas la seule chambre à
juger la proposition de règlement
européen non conforme aux principes de
subsidiarité plusieurs parlements
européens ont adopté ou vont adopter des
avis similaires
si un tiers des parlements nationaux le
font ils envoient un carton jaune à la
Commission européenne qui devra alors se
justifier si plus de la moitié se
prononce dans le même sens elle sera
contrainte de revoir sa copie
pour en savoir plus consultez le site
Internet du Sénat
[Musique]